on cnbc over the weekend uh our gay
transportation secretary pete boudej and
again i only mentioned that he's gay
because it's the only reason he got the
job he's not very good at the job he
took a couple months off right when he
got the job we've had this crazy
all of these transportation problems we
know if his job has is roughly related
to gas prices and things like that uh
supply chain issues et cetera et cetera
so he goes on cnbc and the host just was
not having his nonsense it looked really
tone-deaf i mean what you're telling me
so just stick to the script the economy
is great the border is secure
our cities are safe
no one's pretending
to just be honest wouldn't it be better
to just be
the american people
about the soup that we're in right now
and and we can all try to deal with it
together instead nobody's saying that
our nobody's saying we don't have any
problems but if you don't pause and
recognize the meaning of one of the most
significant pieces of legislation so far
in the 21st century just because we also
have a lot of other problems we're
contending with as a country then then i
think you're really feeding into a
narrative that that's uh pulling america
down and holding america back okay so
that's a fine job by the cnbc host
because pete is just on there going oh
basically everything's okay and then at
the end when he's pushed out well no
one's saying there aren't any problems
but there are massive problems and we
all know it and it's because
of all of the nonsensical policies that
you people have pushed in like critical
race theory and wokeness